hello hey andrea how's it going
well london it has like this weird
reputation it has like this kind of
boring dry
reputation but i think it's very fun
there are a few drawish lines but
yeah well there's different ways to
approach it you can kind of just
play the general setup where you put
your pieces
in the same place every time but then
there's a higher level approach where
you
you react to what your opponent is doing
and at the higher levels
players don't treat the london as just
one system
they treat it as like a few dozen
different
uh different like mini openings that you
kind of have to learn the nuances
exactly it is higher level stuff yeah so
i wanted to ask you maybe just to start
off what are the
the lines that are giving you troubles
or opponents that are giving you
troubles
um okay yeah because that's usually
nothing the queen v6 line alex was
playing
honestly even going over what you played
against us
in the our most recent match is also
good but i don't know if you even have
stuff for that
yeah i've i looked at the one game
i think i know what you're referring to
but also
when you say queen v6 stuff there's
different move orders
black can go for queen b6 so
do you know do you play bishop f4 or
bishop or knight f3 first uh so this is
another thing i was going to ask you
because i usually play bishop f4 on move
two and there's very specific reasons
why i do that
yeah i know you play knight f3 usually
on move too well
lately i've been mixing it up i now i
went back to bishop f4 on move two but
when i would play knight f3 was to
combat the queen b6 line to do
like take c5 line queen takes
i see um yeah that that line from the
fed lack book but
but now i don't really like it as much
because i don't really understand it so
i just played bishop and then if they do
queen b6 i play queen c2
and allow the bishop f5 because you can
take but that's the only line i know
against
can you show me do you know like the
exact move order um because it would be
helpful too
for the queen b6 yeah so like when you
mention
the queen c2 yeah i think it's let me
see if i can just take a guess
it's probably just um
do they push e3 first um so c5
you're probably referring to c5 yeah
and then this is like what most players
do and then they'll either play queen b6
here
yeah one move later one move later after
c3 is because i know if they play now we
play knight b
knight c3 right yeah and that line's
okay but let's say
they would play so um
yeah and then i would play either knight
d2 or c3 and then that's
i only play c3 queen b6 and then queen
here
when i started playing so i don't
recommend that um
okay how do you recognize that so if you
play c3 this is already like
very pleasant for black yeah yeah it is
so annoying to play
uh a lot of players will walk into this
because they're they just learn the
basic setup and then
like after queen b3 this is a very
powerful line for black c4
of course queen i'm sure you've seen
this before
yeah exactly that's why that's why what
i learned or just
temporarily was just to play queen c2
right away because if they play here you
take but then even after
once they defend it or like okay maybe
not like this but
then it's still a very annoying threat
so it's very passive lines so yes
what what do you play instead of so
there's a big difference between
c3 and knight bd2 okay and i saw
based on some of your games you you play
this more often actually
which is great and when you start
approaching the london from like a
higher level
this is one of like the most important
positions to understand how things can
branch out
um because black has a lot of options
here there's queen b6 which we can get
to but then there's also e6 which is
maybe one of the main lines
there's bishop f5 bishop g4
uh there's other weird moves g6 knight
h5 which are a bit less common
of course he takes d4 so this is kind of
one of the the key positions at least to
get to initially and then
as you start expanding your repertoire
you want to kind of know what to do
against each black response
yeah yeah and i'm actually yeah that's
great because a lot of these main lines
have stuff that i've been playing for
really long but i'm curious if even the
main lines you might have different
stuff
so let's follow your lead here yeah and
one of the reasons why i was so
attracted to
london like years ago was because from
this position there's so many
tricky lines and traps that black can
pen potentially fall into
if the players i only know like one i
only know one london trap
so maybe we'll warm up a little bit with
just some
some simple traps just to get you uh
yeah yeah
um one um which is one of my favorites
is bishop g4 here
very natural move uh white play c3
i think i saw you had one game maybe a
few games in this
where you were playing bishop e2 yeah
which i knew
when i studied it i learned you should
go like queen b3 but then i never ended
up playing it okay i'm gonna show you
an even more venomous move awesome
awesome
okay and this is thank you lord
this is really tricky maybe for a few
reasons because not only you're pinning
the knight you're putting pressure
along the fourth rank against the bishop
oh okay i see so maybe future ideas to
take here or so
there's ideas of taking here there's a
lot of resources already
between taking 95 bishop e5
but then there's also a really hidden
resource which a lot of players will
walk into
um on the next move let's imagine bishop
d6
like very natural developing move this
is already losing for black
interesting and it's white to move so
this is kind of a puzzle right to move
and find the move together winning
position
okay great i'll give you i mean yeah go
ahead it seems right away
if you take queen takes oh no actually i
was thinking i wanted
i want to come here to attack the bishop
and try to win a pawn here
um but i didn't want to do it right now
because they could take
um and then i thought i could take but
queen takes would also be defending the
night so then
maybe my move order is messed up thing
oh it's good you're looking at the very
like concrete options
okay so it's a little bit trickier than
that it is trickier
i was going to give you a small clue
that the the arrows that we drew earlier
like this move this move
this move oh wait nice move they're
they're not going to be played here
there's a
interesting a more hidden
much okay so i'm not used to this idea
so it's gonna be a little you have to
think out of the box here yeah
okay but still look for really
aggressive forcing kind of creative
moves
okay i like the challenge let's see
hmm i mean i feel like in a position
like this there's not even that many
abnormal moves
so let's see um
i mean all my forcing moves something
like this something like this something
like this
i don't think any of these are working
keep going just look for any any move
that attacks something that
may be undefended and trying okay no
this
yeah this is
bishop i can't tell if this is a threat
this is an interesting idea actually
bishop a6 looks ridiculous but as you
dig into it further
um you'll realize black just doesn't
have a good response to it
aha so we got it bishop bishop a6 kind
of out of nowhere yeah nice
i think cat got it too i saw a few
people yeah a few people
yeah that's okay though i'm glad
so i've had this uh several times in
like online blitz and players just kind
of stumble into it
it's crazy i've never seen this line
where did you even discover this track
so actually i discovered this just by
kind of playing through the natural
moves for black
having you came up with it um
i mean that's how i discovered it i
think maybe when i've discovered that
there was maybe one or two games in the
database
but it was a pretty fresh idea um at the
time
and that's awesome sometimes like the
way i study openings is not necessarily
from books but i just kind of
i'll play through variations on my own
and then
try and just play logical looking moves
for black have the engine on and see
like where
yeah potential mistakes are makes sense
i don't have enough confidence for that
i always stick to the reference
to the other the gm games it's good to
use a variety of tools like you you can
use
the reference database you can use the
engine you can
kind of base it off your own games too
um i do want to explain like what's
going on here because we just put it
together yeah go ahead and explain the
tactics of
the chat yeah but the threat we just
want to take this pawn and destroy
blacks full queen side
if pawn takes bishop we take on c6
and black is really really suffering
here
um if king e7 i had a game recently um
king e7 queen here
queen d7 takes takes takes
king got to c5 and after check here i'm
triple fork win everything very nice
tactic
so that's just one potential line a lot
of players will take
on f4 and then rather than taking back
the bishop you can play the in between
move take on b7
and you're temporarily down a piece but
black has too many things hanging and
um like every line after bishop a6 is
gonna be
uh like plus two for whites at least
and just to go over so fake castle here
we would take
this bishop first so that they're fourth
here right oh that's a good point yeah
yeah you take the bishop and then you
leave the fourth so then you win the
fourth nice okay
bishop basics makes sense yeah so if you
remember bishop a6 and you can probably
figure out the lines from here um
i'm curious if oh i guess
like if they didn't play bishop d6 yeah
i was going to show
uh just one other like variation to the
trap because some players will take here
um understanding that the bishop is
sometimes a target like they don't want
to deal with knight e5
or the queen alignment and then after
you take back then they'll play bishop
d6
and the great thing about this is bishop
a6 is still winning for white
oh wow um you're winning at least upon
uh there's queen
i guess queen c7 but even this you take
and then
take and uh it just gets really bad for
black
and yeah and then you have a fork don't
you after you're waiting more than a
pawn right yeah actually queen c7 is not
a good move
maybe queen b6 is a better way to go
but then you can still uh
you can still take here and then like
this is probably the best case scenario
yeah
this is a killer end game
so um so there's basically two
variations where bishop a6 works
both of which involve black developing
this bishop to
the most natural square
um there's some other lines here which
of course don't lose material
um knight g7 is probably one of the more
common moves
but then you're playing in a more active
style you have bishop b5 you still have
95 on the horizon
um i think it's much easier to play this
is white like we we could go into more
specifics but if you just remember the
ideas
yeah yeah i have a common idea just one
more question about this position and
then i think like the main idea is
pretty clear
because i've tried these positions
before in my issue
like with this bishop e5 plan is that
often i just trade off my light squared
bishop and i don't really get that much
compensation
so well you're playing bishop b5 not
necessarily for positional reasons
but more for tactical reasons like you
want to you want to try and win material
on the queen side
okay and when you play this you're
threatening the knights
yeah so let's say like black i guess
there's not many ways they did
oh rook here i don't think this the
oh does this defense work yeah roxy
it's a candidate move um i'll just say
i'm not i'm not using the engine here
but as black
if they have to if they want to play
rook c8 they do have to be aware of
takes and takes on these seven
you might just win after white yeah i
think this position is actually
very difficult to play for for black so
i don't ask too many questions here
the plan looks pretty clear if you bring
the knight here
yeah yeah 95 casting bust open the
center like your pieces are all happy
so okay i like it yeah i like it
so queen a5 and bishop a6 i won't forget
this
okay awesome yeah it's it's just one
example of where you stray away from the
traditional london setup
like your bishop didn't go to d3 you
brought out your queen early but you did
it because
black put some their pieces on more kind
of vulnerable squares
yeah that's very funny because the
bishop g4 line was so annoying and
uh i don't know how it's like a one one
move threat but i've never seen this
before so that's that's great
another move i would look forward to
here like whenever black plays bishop g4
i'm really
excited to actually get the trap i'm
also excited when black plays bishop f5
interesting i don't like the setup
because it's so symmetrical
i get so annoyed oh yeah and then it's
harder to maybe develop your bishop
yeah i saw you you had a lot of games
where black like plays in early bishop
f5 then you just trade and it gets
really yeah i always do that just
because it's like yeah it is a really
repetitive and dry position i just play
because it's like oh the most
comfortable thing
gotcha so in this specific position you
can
you can play in a much different style
and you play a move here which you
very often don't play in the london is
pawn takes e5
yeah i never take that pawn i never know
when the right moment is too so i never
do it
ah so this is one of the right moments
because
the bishop is on a square where it's
exploitable because now you're
threatening knight d4
okay so i think actually i did look at
this before and then i completely forgot
about it
so i'm glad you're bringing it up again
it's good to do a refresher and like
continually
kind of yeah it's definitely been a long
time
but yeah the point after e6 of course
black wants to win back the pawn
you play knight d4 and now you're
threatening to get the bishop pair
destroy black's pawn structure
and then black has to kind of make a
decision do they take the pawn and
and allow you to take on f5 or do they
try and save the bishop
after which you're going to get a lot of
a lot of initiative
so just to show you a few ways black can
like lose material really quickly
imagine bishop g6
i'm pretty sure you're already winning
the exchange by force
you're winning an exchange yes you have
a nice tactical sequence
from this position and it starts with a
very natural kind of developing
attacking
um i mean first instinct would be here
vision b5 and develop with tempo okay
black would play
queen d7 ah queen g7 is actually maybe a
bit more
challenging we'll address queen g7 i
want to look at rook
c8 first okay because then from this
position
uh how do you win the rook by force
oh oh we trap it we take pawn takes and
bishop a6
very nice yeah takes takes bishop he's
here to find out because i
i remember bishop a6 as an idea already
yeah it's a very typical like london
tactic where the bishops work together
if rookie you you feed caddo in black's
territory
nice the rook is trapped um
so yeah rook c8 doesn't quite work if
queen g7
i'll admit i don't remember actually
studying this move but i
i'm pretty sure we just played knight f3
and 95
is really hard to deal with oh yeah
that's true and
yeah black is can't castle no matter
what yet so
yeah it looks like a lot of we're ahead
in development here
yeah i'm checking with engine knight f3
it's already plus one
um oh the best try for black is bishop
h5
but then you can play b4 and just hold
on to your pawn
yeah and this is very comfortable i mean
all your pieces are developed yeah
this is a great position yep yeah it's
like a very good version of a queen's
gambit accepted
where you you won the pawn and you have
a lot of initiative too
very nice so um so more people will
probably take but then you take and um
this is considered like slightly better
for whites because you have the bishop
okay good i was gonna ask if you bring
this bishop to d3 which
seems but i mean it can get i mean i
guess you'll have time for a3 right so
you don't so when you play bishop d3 you
are threatening the pawn
yeah and then you have time for a move
like c3 or a3 yeah there's different
ways to play this
okay yeah i don't often play positions
where we are missing the d-pawn so
i never know if we still want to go for
the d3 setup
or we're just waiting maybe go for c4
gotcha
yeah i usually like to play so there's
there's pros and cons with c3 and c4
when black has isolated pawn it can be a
very good strategy to control the square
in front of the pawn so control the d4
square so then the pawn can never move
forward and then you can
potentially target later on with like
queen f3 with d1
yeah and that's the most like natural
set up here anyway
so yeah it's very natural it's hard for
black to get like
like very active play and then you just
kind of want to play positionally and
this pawn is going to be a long-term
target okay great
yeah i'm trying to think if there's like
a different move order where they can
play bishop f5
there is i guess when they don't push c5
right
yeah and that that will go so i guess we
were looking from kind of this key
position after knight d2
yeah um but there's of course other move
orders where black will play bishop f5
let's say here
yeah yeah then in that case you would
play with the bishop d3 idea
so there's actually a couple ideas i can
i can give you here
um but the one i usually enjoy playing
let's say they just keep copying
is you can go for c4 um
with a slightly different setup because
usually in london you play c3
but with c4 the planets will play queen
b3
target the b pawn which is not defended
and then
also knight c3 and pressure the center
all these lines are all
lines that i did study and i said i'd
play i totally forgot about this one i'm
glad you're bringing these up
i i love when you get the queen b3 as a
white so that's good we're recovering
some suppressed memories of your opening
practice
exactly they are suppressed memories um
yeah so it's so important especially
when
like as a london player if if you do
forget what
what to do like or you forget your
preparation that when you play games you
go back and like
look afterwards what your preparation
actually was
because that's the way you'll you'll
continue to grow for sure
um a lot of players will play c6 here
i'm kind of playing this
what we can call reverse london and then
what you can do is queen b3
let's say queen b6 and you get kind of a
reverse version
yeah of the line that we saw earlier but
now you're the one dropping
i played this line a good amount of time
normally black doesn't go into
this and they'd play like queen c8 or
something
it's another option yeah but i couldn't
see it then you just continue developing
normally
yeah queen c8 you uh you'll have a
slight space advantage
um where yeah knight c3 bishop e2
castling black doesn't have the d6
square for the bishop
yeah oh man i remember i did i had this
line in so many tournaments and then
when i got into streaming and i never
looked at my repertoire i never played
it online
but i remember this like i've had these
this in tournament games so
oh interesting okay yeah it's it's
slightly better for white and it's
usually something
like black is just not super comfortable
with
um just one more idea to play h3 dealing
with potential knight h5
give the bishop a square to to go back
and okay
you can you can go for like the long
term positional squeeze from
the sort of position um
so yeah like one way to kind of kind of
remember
the strategy is when they develop the
bishop
you recognize that b-pawn's not defended
and then you switch things up with c4
queen b3
okay got it um of course in the other
line
in the c5 line you recognize that the c5
is not defended
so you just look at which which pawn is
their weakness
exactly i'm trying to find uh yeah so
with bishop f5 here
then you can take and you have knight d4
so
okay perfect i'll remember this i'll
never forget
okay i'm i'm holding you to that promise
um maybe we can look at queen b6
in this position oh okay yeah yeah this
was the main
yeah this was the line i had no idea
what to do but i'm glad you went over
bishop
bishop f5 because that's also an
important one okay yeah that was nice we
covered that
do you take on c5 uh yes you take on c5
also thank you yeah for the giant raid i
appreciate that
i gotta let me grab something give me
two seconds oh yeah this is another
line i'm i'm super excited to show
because there's some really cool ideas
there's some some nice traps and it's
super venomous
i studied this and then there was a
point to where like i
i even following with the computer lines
like i didn't really like my position so
i'm really glad that you brought this
one up
so this is another line i checked your
games i saw it was clear that you
studied
this at some point yeah yeah yeah you
went into like i know what to do after
some point yeah this this took me a long
time to like fully understand it's it's
a process with like learning
especially a shark variation yeah not
only you have to study it but you have
to get experience
and um actually get in in games
but the point in this variation you do
give away the b-pawn
very often you give away the c-pawn
and then you play it as kind of a gambit
where you you play very aggressively and
then you
get a lot of active play so
this is the main line bishop yes i
remember this
and the thing to point out right away is
you've developed all your minor pieces
it's
a relatively open position you have the
half open b file
black's a bit underdeveloped the queen's
a target
so a lot of players like won't be
so booked up here as black and if you
can
if you can do like a little bit of
preparation from here as white you
should hopefully get
like a position that you you know what's
going on
yeah i'll i'll show you the line we're
we're getting into it almost
there so i never know play against
first of all if queen takes c5 which is
a natural looking move you have c4
and i don't know if i want to go too
much beyond this because most people
don't actually take on c5
yeah and uh it's pleasant like the
queen's still at target
might be three ideas c file opening
potentially you're gonna castle soon
um more people will play e6
yeah e6 is the line that i have troubles
with because eventually black just gets
to castle and like
your your advantage and development is
doesn't make a huge difference anymore
okay i'm going to show you a really cool
a few years ago is novelty
and it's a relatively new
here ah so i saw you have a game with
with knight e5
uh oh okay so you don't want yourself
that was what i okay cool because this
yeah 95 here's the line that i studied
from sedlak's book which was like oh
this is
now what you must play against queen v6
and
and then i just not really like the
positions i got into
i'm pretty sure zedlock's book came out
before
this novelty was interesting it was
introduced
uh there's a move here which i'm pretty
sure it was a novelty in this famous
alpha zero versus stockfish match where
alpha zero just came up with a move that
if you travel
yeah i think like they were programmed
to try to go into like
very topical openings so this is one
line they went into and alpha zero just
came up with uh
a room i love all the history so it's
such a refined culture this is a novelty
of the london yeah yeah it was um it was
a
sort of thing like if you turned on
stockfish a
few years ago it wouldn't come up with
this move but alpha zero came up with it
and it's super super venomous
um so i'll just show the move and then
then we'll we'll analyze because it is
sharp
is to play point four okay
it's another sort of pawn sacrifice
because you're your pawn's attack twice
obviously it's only defended once
but if black takes it either way you're
gonna get
very close to winning position actually
i'm pretty sure it's winning no matter
which way black takes
crazy i have no idea how that is winning
yeah so with with variations like this
it's not enough to just memorize the
moves you you really have to understand
yeah what's going on i don't understand
the main idea
one of the points is that there's
there's variations where the queen just
gets trapped
that's what i was thinking imagine
pawn takes pawn there's a crazy crazy
move here
i'm debating to i'll give it as a puzzle
but maybe i'll give you a chance so it's
late to move
okay yeah i was thinking this is what i
was calculating as soon as you push
b4 like nice some idea to to come here
to try to pin the queen and you could
even
sack your knights the only issue you
guys think of this move is if they would
castle but
and knight c4 would control this square
and this square
and the queen can't run anywhere here
and if they
oh yeah and then if they take this
should be winning the queen
you have absolutely the right idea um
knight c4 is
is brilliant yeah that's what i was
thinking
and then they could castle those so they
don't have to take so the one
thing the one thing to spot is not only
is bishop e5 a threat but also bishop d2
so you don't even have to worry about
the square being covered by the knife
okay
um and actually after knight c4 it's
pretty much impossible for black to stop
bishop d2 and you're just winning the
queen oh yeah so if a castle you would
just play bishop
d2 uh yeah
okay yeah i mean most people will take
the knight and realize that their queen
is hopeless but
same thing castlings castling bishop d2
sorry mel slipping here play like um
rookie eighth
so rook diet you're still gonna win
material
and sometimes this will happen like when
you trap a queen you won't actually win
a full queen you'll win like some
material for it so in this case i guess
after all said and done
you're up extreme so even after the
night you're up material i thought
yeah you can throw in this move too but
okay
um yeah knight c4 is is really nice most
people will take
and then oh actually
in this position sorry bishop d2 you
don't want to play here
because queen d4 oh i see
yes think oh but you have rook b3
rook b3 is the line
does bishop e5 uh so okay
this is important and i'm actually
learning something new here too so
just turn on the engine to check uh rook
b3 is the only winning move
if you play bishop e5 you do trap the
queen
the problem is black's getting a lot of
material for the queen after
queen takes c4 you take back
oh i see n the [ __ ] yeah three minor
pieces for the queen okay make sure box
probably for choice here
yeah okay with rook b3
keep in mind you you did give away a
knight but the most black can get for
the queen now
is a rook and then you'll have queen for
rook and minor piece
okay um so i've trapped a few people in
this
and and online blitz and bullets yeah no
this is this is a great line
because i have to remember rook b3
so yeah remember i guess to understand
this so you you
even if you forget hopefully you can
figure thing things out yeah
is you play e4 to the [ __ ]
yeah yeah you deflect the pawn from c4
so to get knight c4 and then you have
either rook b3 or bishop d2
okay um
now there's another line here
involving knight takes e4
which is also really really beautiful
for this one i think i'll just show you
okay go for it
i i will say it's it's not so practical
to memorize because
most people won't go into this but it's
nice to know
is after takes takes
you have another like really surprising
move again and this is
something new or sorry um you're gonna
take your first
so you play a few forcing moves this
position you have a really surprising
move
um you can show me how to yeah i'm just
going to show you because
you're going to leave the knight
undefended or uh leave the knight
attacked
and play bishop d6 interesting
and this is kind of engine inspired but
uh
computer will say white's running here
this definitely looks like a computer
line but it is
the whole point is your
you're taking advantage of the fact that
king is still in the center
so black just doesn't have time to
castle if black takes on f3
you're quick enough to take on e7 okay
threatening maiden one
king e7 and then you just keep throwing
punches queen g6
oh yeah and then you get the king f6
rook b3 it's
absolutely crushing wow yeah this is a
this is a crazy line this is awesome
so when we think like when most people
think london opening they don't envision
like this craziness but
tactical lines but it's so fun like once
you
you start playing this and you remember
the lines and a lot of players yeah
i really like the e4 line it's way
better than the positions i would get
into from this line
and the reason i couldn't find a good
position was the reason i stopped
playing that line and then
just get really bad positions from queen
v6 so e4 here is
fantastic yeah e4 it's nice to um
to go into a sharp line where there's a
lot of landmines for the opponent to
fall into
and like the best move here is castling
but then it still leads to a playable
position
um and then the stockfish alpha zero
game
it went uh chad said that you make the
london look
fun oh that's a that's a nice compliment
and and someone asked who came up with
it i'm assuming that
both of those traps you discovered by
analyzing with the computer right
uh yeah so openings are not necessarily
invented but they're
they're discovered um so some
some lines i i see just from analyzing
with engine
sometimes it's like looking at high
level games
and then then still using the engine
sometimes it's like videos or books
so it was a discovery chat better
appreciated exactly a novelty
yeah so here i don't want to spend too
much more time on this yeah but uh
i'll share one more just nice trick
knight g7
you play knight p3 and
after knight b3 black has one move not
to lose a queen because you're
threatening
bishop d2 oh okay only move that doesn't
matter if this is hanging here
yeah black takes on e5 then yeah
you don't have to follow then then takes
takes bishop d2 traps the queen oh so
you don't do it right away
uh there is some knight f3 queen f6 oh
gosh
yeah okay good good good to know so the
only move not to lose for black is queen
b4
uh sorry in this position queen b4
which is hard to play because it aligns
the queen with the rook
um but then okay this uh
this is the alpha zero stockfish game
the play went on
i think um like knight d4 was played and
white got some eventual attack on the
king side
um so people want to like analyze that
game
it's there's some videos covering it on
youtube
so one thing another difference between
night off three on move two and bishop
f4
is a way in which you can handle king's
indian setups from black
yeah i was i i was gonna ask you why you
play against king's indian
and this is yeah this is kind of going
into another branch of london because
we were looking at lines where black
plays d5 early
but there's lines where black will play
g6 or g6 or sometimes c5 here
oh c5 oh
i mean i guess i'm not gonna be playing
knight f3 on on move one so it's c5
on move two is totally fine actually
because you can just push e3 so this is
actually one of the benefits with
playing vision f4
on move two is if your knight was here
and black plays this you you can't play
bishop f4
yeah exactly actually i'll show you a
funny trap if you play bishop f4 here
there's takes takes
and then e5 wins a piece yeah i've had
this done against me yeah yeah i don't
think i'm gonna play knight f3 on move
today i've fallen for this a few times
you learn the hardest terrible yes
definitely gonna stick to bishop f4 now
one move two so after bishop f4
c5 you get an e3
some players will play queen b6 here
actually there is a very popular video
released not too long ago from again
mater
and he was okay he was sharing his
anti-london
and recommending this move and what do
you have in rebuttal
so there's a move in this position which
he didn't cover in the video
we should make a rebuttal to his video
yeah um actually levy levy made a
rebuttal to the video where he
shows he showed knight a3 i think he
showed some some other lines too
but um 93 is actually a nice idea here
i was just i always get so tilted when
there's a video it's like the
best line against the london it'll crush
it
but okay to explain what's going on here
because whenever the queen comes to b6
in london
it's so typical to move the knight to c3
to respond to queen b2 with knight b5
yeah yeah
oh this is typical but it's probably not
what you play if you play knight c3 in
this position
there's a6 and then
it gets weird because then you don't
have knight b5
reason for playing knight a3
is you're also looking to go to c4
so you're gonna get one of these moves
okay
it takes a transposes this is this is a
sharp line i don't think i want to get
into most players
yeah yeah you don't need to um actually
one funny thing though i
i played hikaru in this with this line
as white he played knight t5 i played
rook b1
he took i played rook a1 and white can
force a draw
by just perpetually attacking the queen
yeah
so in my game he sacked his queen for
the rook and ended up losing
oh wow you you beat hikaru with this
london line
actually so the video is on youtube i
called it beating
hikaru's botest gambit because he sat he
said
awesome oh i'm gonna i'm gonna find that
video after that
that's crazy he actually he almost came
back to beat me but then i i dirty
flattered
and that's very impressive so if you
play this against a really high rated
player you can
force a draw if you play this against
akaro he might go insane and then you
you beat him
yeah i mean i think he car would just
stack his queen and beat me but
that's okay yeah i think he's learned
his lesson not to go into this line
against like a much lower yeah
probably won't play knight d5 well
that's very impressive that's awesome
oh thank you so the other thing because
most players won't take on
on b2 yeah uh they'll play a move like
d6 or a6
after which you play knight c4 hating
the queen and defending the pawn
that i was thinking and and then from
there you would go with normal
so from here the queen has to retreat
and you go for normal london development
exactly
that makes a lot of sense and it's like
your knight is just stronger than
typical and they wasted
two moves with their queen yep yeah it's
still playable for black but
it's still very very solid would
um white play like an a4 to prevent
something
here yeah a4 is very typical to
discourage the b5 push and okay
um makes sense yeah i've had my fair
share of games here but
a lot of players won't be prepared for
knight a3
because they'll have watched again
mater's video they'll they'll go into
this and they they just knock their
surprises on i can't wait till yeah
because i haven't had like you know
really
top level theory games and i'm just
playing blitz against 1900s but i can't
wait to tell i'm in a tournament
and like you can finally use these lines
yeah it's super fun and it's also fun to
like prepare
for specific players and see what they
play against the london
and then then try and target like their
their weaknesses in whatever variation
they go to
which maybe can transition we can segue
to
how you would play against your sister
because she plays king's indian yes she
says
she didn't play it in our match because
she was trying your lines but what she
was playing wasn't good so we'll
definitely prepare against kane's indian
yeah like a pet lion that i would play
but
okay what's your what's your pet line
i'm assuming
i think do you play king's indian or no
i don't know if we played it in as black
i usually don't i like to play against
it though
okay okay i think it's dania who would
always play it but i mean i just go like
typical eat i always play bishop e2 and
then most of the time i go for c4 and
that's kind of
gotcha i've seen yeah i checked your
games and
what you do it's very solid there's
nothing wrong with it
yeah but there's definitely probably
more exciting lines if you want to have
more
fun in life you can start with knight c3
here
oh i had a coach who tried to take and
i'm pretty sure
and then i i just never wanted to do it
because it just
it seems so different yeah yeah but it's
really not a huge difference
but is it like are you gonna go for e4
queen d2 the whole point is to trick
a king's indian player into a
pierce where if they play bishop g7
which i see you you play as black
yeah i do play this is more of a pierce
defense where white didn't commit to c4
true that's true yeah so there's lines
with queen d2 casting queen side and
just destroying black
on the king side yeah my i did look at
this my coach did recommend it before
and then
i i think i just also forgot about it
but yeah with the h4 idea and it's
honestly
it's not too uncomfortable to play at
all with queenside castle
yeah it takes some upfront work to like
get experience
but i think it's well worth the time
yeah i agree so many players play the
king's indian and a lot of them just
aren't so well prepared for this idea
because king's indian like usually it's
black the one attacking on the king side
yeah but then they have to switch up
their entire style so even if you're
like a little bit prepared here
you can usually be more prepared than
most of your opponents
great i definitely i do want to try some
new lines so
that aren't like the typical structures
i like the 93 idea and when i play
king's indian as black the h4 attack is
always the most annoying
that is what alex crushes me with as
well i was gonna say like
this this could be something you
might have trouble with is black because
yeah i struggle with it for sure with
things in the end
yeah it's like it's so direct for white
and um like one of the best ways to kind
of
learn this deeper how to deal with it
with with black is is to start playing
it with white
yeah i know this is awesome um so i i
actually i checked your black games like
what you do from this position
yeah i saw some different things once in
a while i always
yeah i think most of the time you play
d6 but in some
games you castled which is already a
mistake because white has e5
yeah the idea is i learned that
i think it has to be not against the
london but
it must be when they have like a pawn
here or a pawn here that sometimes i
want to provoke it to go into some sort
of line like this but
definitely not against the london that's
just me being sloppy with my
openings as black yeah a lot of players
will actually do this in bullet like
they'll just kind of mix up the move
order allow yeah
it's good in this position because if
black plays knight h5
it's actually a typical move to attack
the bishop yes
you can very calmly move back to d2
now threatening g4 to trap the knights
right
this is already much much better for
whites yeah
i mean d6 doesn't work bishop h8 is so
sad ugly
yeah it's terrible you probably started
the e8
yeah yeah you play g4 and laugh at box
pieces
yeah no the e5 line is a killer for sure
yeah and if 98 then you play
you can start with knight f3 and this
knight's going to be restricted by the
pawn
pawn is very well supported and then you
still go for the
h4 queen d2 idea right you could still
go for that you can play positionally in
the center too there's different
approaches here
but uh okay here you go we don't need to
spend too much time on this one because
once you get e5 you have some more space
it makes sense
yeah yeah i think time is better spent
with d6
yeah because most players will kind of
walk into this
and then let's say castling castling
and if this is kind of new to you it
takes it takes a lot of experience to
fully understand um
yeah i definitely want to try it though
so but the first step is kind of trying
and
you're going to be in kind of new
situations early on but if you can take
away lessons from every game that you
play
um yeah analyze them you can be very i
will try this slide and learn
100 so maybe i can show you just like
one
kind of common sequence a lot of players
will
kind of just stumble into even like very
strong players
let's imagine c6 here good as a common
move
i'm actually gonna see so uh last night
i actually i made a file
on like a kind of annotated pgn file
on london versus king's indiana
i'm gonna paste it in here
and i'll be happy to like send this to
you afterwards
oh thank you so much i really appreciate
that you took so much time to prepare
this this is so helpful this is awesome
oh yeah it was like i realized yesterday
i didn't have like a clear
like prep file on on this exact line so
it was uh
it was definitely nice to have the
motivation to actually make it
that's great eric's fantastic
coach ever oh well thank you
i'm trying anyway i want to show you
just a nice sequence
it's actually a game that i played a few
years ago against
a pretty strong grand master was over
the board blitz tournament
where i kind of used all the thematic
ideas he is playing that this is like
the main line
oh it's with queen a5 but he finds
another move
yeah actually recommended but
i even when i play that line as black
because right i play king's indian
it's still so tough so i'll show you
just one thing with queen a5
okay there's a really important
defensive sequence white should use here
um starting with king b1
this is kind of the ben feingold rule
like always play king b1
okay and the point is that
very often you can maneuver the knight
to c1
where it's super super safe so if if
before
you play knight e2 bishop e60 c1
okay yeah this is very solid it makes
sense if you don't
do this and um like sometimes it's easy
to get carried away on the king side
and then it's easy to run into trouble
but if you get the knight to c1
it's really hard for black to crack
white's position okay
um and we'll see something similar
in the main line that i have here so if
we imagine black storms with the pawns
always play king b1 as soon as after
you've castled
pretty much yeah there's usually not a
like if you're considering playing it
it's usually not a bad move
yeah yeah you always have time for the
king move i'll remember that that's
something i didn't know
that i never castle queenside yeah it's
one of those things
like usually you castle kingside and
then you don't have to worry about
so from here like white's already
accomplished the first step of the plan
getting the bishop here
the next step is to just push the h pawn
open the h file and then get the
checkmating attack
and this is from your game right so this
is a game yeah i was against fidel
corrales
uh two years ago and like he he's a
really like dangerous attacking player
so he was trying to destroy me
yeah this is so bold i've never seen
this
where you just go all the way for the
queen side push yeah
he just wanted to open up the the fight
so a nice response here is to take and
then
keep things closed play a3 yeah i just
leave the pawn on b3 and it kind of
slows down black's attack
makes sense he played queen a5 trying to
trade queens
i just brought the knight back to c3
still having ideas of this
played knight h5 going for this move
i cover the square and then we traded
and the common theme for like these sort
of positions it's just really hard to
stop the
incoming attack yeah so he tried some
stuff
but i'm already yeah it's crazy
you have like no pieces by your king
side but black can't do anything
yeah as long as like the pawns stay
stable then uh
yeah then it's hard for black to do much
so you really try like he tried to get
my queen stuck because the queen defends
but uh the problem with g5 it leaves h7
as a target
and i went for this and e5 and then this
was hard to stop
wow this is a this is a beautiful line
this is a great game here
oh thank you yeah like after i played
the game i immediately went to my
my laptop to like put in them yes before
i it's a great instructional game
so one more
one more variation from this position
after d6 queen d2
uh i think it's it's already in the file
that i loaded in
um but i looked at alexandra's games
and she plays a really weird move here
like her most played move is it's
strange looking there's some logic to it
i'm wondering if neriditsky showed it to
her is this
maybe oh no i don't think
i don't think they came up with this he
did a little bit of prep but not this
one
okay alexandra's weird move of choice
oh man i'm so motivated to just
challenge her after this without even
know
yeah um
well i'll show you what i i kind of
discovered because i found a cool line
which it's very easy for black to
stumble into
okay and first of all there is some
logic like i've i've encountered this
move from some strong players
in blue yes i don't really know
like i think i've analyzed it before
defending as black and
i don't actually really know how we
white can still break through the pawn
structure otherwise then like use the g5
square for their knights
so the point of h5 is to slow down
lights attack like there's no bishop h6
it's harder to play g4 so if you go for
the typical plan
very often black can leave the king in
the center
and then do things on the queen side and
if you don't know what you're doing you
could get into trouble
yeah yeah i have looked at this a little
bit before for black i think
so this is one example of where you
should switch things up
and rather than put the pawn on f3 in
castle right away you're going to focus
in the center
play knight f3 okay wait so in
but in the previous game we didn't have
f3 right but f3 is just kind of like the
movie
is like a typical move yeah usually
reinforcing this if your night life goes
up
oh yeah that is what alex was playing
against me f3 oh okay
yeah it's a typical move and mostly i
think she got it from you probably
because she's
analyzed your play against pizza if you
play f3 that's why you're playing it
yesterday
uh interesting um
so after h5
you play knight f3 first of all you do i
the g5 square because black never has h6
but you also prepare this move e5
right and i saw alex had one game in
this position
she played knight d7 very natural
looking move
but knight g7 is
practically losing it it leads to like
really really nice position for
for white after pawn e5 yeah because the
knight has nowhere to go the knight yeah
the knight no longer has h5
and there's many lines where you play e6
if we look at one example line let's say
trade
trade knight g4 very natural hitting the
pawn
yeah you can you can basically paralyze
lack
just by castling and now you create the
pin
along the d-file so
like black can't take the pawn because
uh the queen is gonna be lost in the end
yeah no this is great i was thinking a3
but i mean it was kind of pointless
after knight h6 so castling makes so
this is another point if if black
castles
you play h3 the knights trapped nice
again still
black can't take without losing a piece
because of the pin
if not here you the um the bishop just
takes
okay so i looked further here it gets
better
because let's imagine like black plays a
natural move like c6
and this is usually how i study like i
was i had the engine turned on but i was
still trying to play through like
what what the human would do from this
position yeah i mean it's really already
really tough to play as black
um yeah so c6 looks like a logical
attempt to like move the queen maybe
so here you you keep developing bishop
c4
now let's say queen a5 natural
trying to escape the pin now threatening
the pawn
four times um
i discovered this all last night here
the engine spits out like a really
brilliant variation
bishop takes f7
king takes f7 e6 check dragging the king
into the open king takes e6 yeah brutal
i have to be sure don't don't share this
with alexandra before you
you play her kingdom
these are fantastic lines yeah these the
the two chops that you showed winning
the queen
they're very cool um
yeah so it's like another like there's
all these hidden gems if black plays
something offbeat or
slightly obvious where you can yeah i
mean this line is just
killing for white even the queenside
castle it's
over yeah even after like
after e5 engine gives like plus 1.87
right so um i mean
and i feel like most ideas for black if
they don't castle
right away couldn't you go oh i guess
there's always the knight h5 so that's
why you can't use this idea more often
uh yeah there's very specific cases
where you should
should play e5 and should keep your pawn
back but this is one case where black
just didn't have a great square for the
night and black was underdeveloped
this is great um
maybe i i can share like one more i'm
just trying to convince you to start
playing this so i'm trying to give you
as much information as possible i'm so
motivated after this so i'm gonna just
go play blitz and just wait for my games
as white and i'm gonna try out every
line
here oh that's exciting very motivated
so i want to share one more trap like
from this position just a very
natural way that can end up losing
material very early
and the way i discovered this trap and
it's just another way sometimes i'll
study openings
is i played i played out this position
against stockfish
but i played the black side oh
and i had stockfish play white and i was
just trying to play like natural
human moves and stockfish completely
obliterated me found like a nice looking
tactic
um and it still played like very kind of
thematic ideas
so i played knight d7 here yeah very
very common
yeah always going for e5 yeah e5 c5
typical
ideas yeah um here you don't have to
waste any time play bishop h6
and this is where i um i went for c5
like trying to challenge this oh this
makes sense so far yep
um and here the engine came up with like
very concrete idea
now actually every move white will play
for the rest of the game
is either a capture or a threat so it's
pure initiative
starting with bishop takes g7
king g7 another case where e5 is
uh is very timely aha because the queen
is going to be hanging again so again
this x-ray vision
yeah if black takes takes there's a pin
and
it's already really bad for black so
another thing to point out black can't
take with a counter attack because you
take with check
okay nice so i realized okay i'm under
pressure move the knight back
trying to hold on to the pawns and now
white keeps initiative takes talk of
knight
takes took with knight white to move
and force resignation one more move
and then i just resigned against uh
against stockfish
okay well i mean obviously there's a
fork but yep simple enough you're just
cool oh that's yeah okay okay that was
like more complicated because i was like
oh it wasn't like a may 4th maiden
no very this was a more like simple
tactic but i wanted to show the sequence
just as another
another source of inspiration oh yeah
let me go over it just so i can
so i know e4 okay e40 was if they only
the only defending move of the pawn and
then you just have a
fourth fork okay makes sense gotcha
yeah and here if they don't take then
you're just up a pawn and
you still have a lot of pressure too
like that yeah it gets kicked around
wow so okay so they're both e4 ideas
gotcha
i mean yeah e5 yeah yeah
and if you're ever unsure like it's
something you can calculate because it's
usually a concrete line
yeah but uh like variations like this
the lines kind of flow very nicely where
you you keep throwing punch after punch
even starting with bishop h6 it was uh
pretty crazy because all of black's
moves are completely natural from main
ideas in the king's indian
so this is definitely a strong line
exactly and just another reason why i
love the london is because if
if black is playing naturally like they
can just walk into landmines i actually
need to figure out what to do as
as black against this yeah
i was thinking that too because you you
would probably stumble into like some of
these positions
why can't you play e5 instead of c5
i mean it's still really passive but oh
it's true so
here and here so with e5
you typically will have the same
attacking ideas on the king side um you
probably want to start by taking
here because your queen is a bit
overworked
right um yeah yeah those are the threads
and you start by taking
whatever black takes back with i'd
probably include
f3 and still go for this sort of kings
okay so that's
the typical plan for white yeah i'm just
checking with the engine to verify
but um yeah engine engine is giving
white close to plus one here
yeah i mean that makes sense because the
natural move is pawn takes but then you
have to worry about how to develop your
bishop because
your knights and your queen is black
black is really slow to develop and
really slow to attack
yeah like eventually oh i think in this
i i definitely had positions like this
and then like
eventually i survived trying to move my
queen and then slowly take out my bishop
but it is really slow
the the problem here because it's
obsolete castling
these positions usually come down to who
can attack quicker
yeah and because black's play is so slow
and white white can just
launch forward with h4 um yeah computer
is giving a very solid plus one
okay um ideas of h5
let's just say i'll play as black you
play as white yep um
okay i'm
sorry i had the engine turned on it was
suggesting h5 for a moment
which it leads to like kind of more
difficult lines to understand
i would be more inclined to play f3 here
preparing g4 h5
okay yeah i just yeah you don't even
have to give like the best computer
lines just
to see like your main ideas as white
because you play this set up a lot with
f3
absolutely yeah so then once you come in
with
h5 yeah yeah h5 i mean this this thread
is huge because then you're
trying to checkmate me um yeah it's hard
to resolve for luck
we do have the night defending for now
right but then you're throwing
let's see i'm curious how you'll play
okay let's continue actually maybe
takes on
well let's play h5 immediately okay so
here i was thinking
if you take and you go for g5 i have
knight here so i thought let's say let's
just say i did something normal like
this
i don't think there's a mate probably
want to take
yeah that's actually true if i take on
g6 or takes queen h6 the king goes back
it's hard to oh you think with the s not
the h pawn
oh yeah so if it takes one yeah
yeah so just curious here what would so
one
plan is to still go for this
and queen h6 king g8 and go for knight
h3 to g5
okay um and then just continue adding
pressure
uh if the light can come to g5 and you
can remove this bishop then maybe you
can get your bishop to the the diagonal
yeah yeah that makes sense because like
queen g7 then you have at least this
double attack
so okay so you still have this nagging
pressure
king is very safe um but again
this is this would be something i would
check with the engine yeah
um it's actually so in this position
engine gives like
another kind of weird-looking idea but
it's giving plus two after queen g5
because this is oh this yes is engine
move
but which i definitely you have a really
good habit by
looking by doing your openings with
stock fish i always go only like human
moves books
i never think outside of the box and i
always stick to the same ideas
so it's nice like using the engine when
studying openings
it it's a really good tool if you use it
appropriately
like you you can't just kind of get lazy
and look at all the engine
yeah not make an effort to understand
the position of course
but sometimes if you dig deeper and then
realize like oh it's kind of hard for
black to defend the pawn you're pinning
the knight
uh okay there's still the pressure of
of doing the stuff so yeah yeah yeah i
mean
white could play black could have played
like bishop d7 said but i'll i'll
definitely analyze these but these are
all
this is very helpful i will try this
setup i like the f3 idea it seems very
solid
yeah it's just another thematic idea in
the opening and i don't want to
overwhelm you
with like too many words but this has
all been so great
that's good yeah yeah i think the whole
point was to give you some inspiration
and trying you definitely did the weak
spot
yeah i just like i gave up on studying
the london for so long and
the fact that most of these lines are
better than what i would even study in
the book
is so helpful you can't find them
anywhere so this is great
thank you so much eric and i'd love to
do this again
and we should also have another rematch
soon yeah i don't know what you're gonna
do now when i have your lines i don't
know
you'll play against us but i'm sure
you'll come up you'll come up with
something i'm sure of it